so Ben you know obviously you've got
Democrats there saying that President
Trump it's a constitutional crisis but
doesn't it also have a destabilizing
effect to try to weaponize impeachment I
mean it has a destabilizing effect I
think for Democrats more than it does
for the country I mean the fact is that
the Democrats at the top know that the
worst thing that they can do right now
is push impeachment preemptively before
any crime has been committed because
nothing is going to rally Trump space or
alienate moderates quite like a stupid
impeachment hearing by the same token
you know the idea that the Democrats
have been pushing for since the election
which is that Donald Trump is a not the
Donald Trump is a constitutional danger
that he's an incipient Hitler well that
means that a lot of Democratic base is
saying well if all that's true you need
to get rid of him
do whatever you can get rid of them now
so they have to split in their base that
they can't exactly rectify so it's weird
to hear people like Nancy Pelosi and Tom
Perez saying well you know that's not
really a priority well once you ratchet
the urgency level up to 11 how is that
not a priority what what is the reality
here though let's say Democrats take
back the house is this something you see
them actually moving forward I mean I
think it will be a heavy push for
impeachment from at least half of the
Democrats in Congress and I think that
once that ball starts rolling it can be
very difficult to stop because are you
gonna be the Democrat who wants to go on
the record voting against impeachment of
President Trump right if someone
actually brings that to the floor so
that it's gonna be a real sticking point
for them again they've gone over their
skis when it comes to the the radicalism
of their calls about President Trump